the Father and Son facing offer control
of the family Legacy a damaged daughter
willing to destroy a brother for her
father's sake where are Yellowstone's
Shakespearean scale characters headed in
season 5. opening the season with a
two-hour event Yellowstone season 5 is
set to premiere on November 15 2022.
Paramount has been on a roll lately with
Yellowstone adjacent content as the
network has greenlit multiple Taylor
Sheridan held spin-off series including
1883 1923 and 666 proving that they're
all in on Yellowstone recently Ceres
executive producer David C Glasser
caught up with Hello magazine to promote
the next season saying that episode 1
will immediately surprise everybody
where our story starts and what has
happened it sounds like he's implying a
series time jump in the Yellowstone
narrative or some other major event to
kick off the next season while we're
hard-pressed to figure out how you could
start a new season with more intensity
than season four there's no doubt that
Sheridan and Company will deliver and it
will be explosive the next installment
of the Dutton family Saga arrives just
in time for Thanksgiving some Dynamic
bands genuinely thankful the central
cast members of Yellowstone are expected
to return for season five this includes
Kevin Costner's Dutton family patriarch
John Kelly Riley is Bath Cole Hauser's
rip Wes Bentley is Jamie Luke Grimes as
Casey and Kelsey asbold as Monica not to
mention Jefferson white is Jimmy and a
host of others from the bunk house when
season 4 ended Casey was immersed in a
Native American ritual that cut him off
from the world only to have a spiritual
revelation of his own I saw a universe
there's plenty of speculation as to what
Casey meant with luck we'll learn the
answer in the season premiere the fifth
season is guaranteed to bring a new
sheriff to town following the death of
Donnie Haskell played by Hugh Dillon
it's possible that an existing character
will step into the role Matthew Jones
introduced as the sheriff's deputy in
season 4 is a possibility sadly Will
Patton who played Jaime's biological
father Garrett Randall won't be
returning since Jaime killed him in the
season 4 finale however Katherine
Cunningham who plays Christina is likely
to return since she and Jaime have a
child together how will that play out
now that Beth has Jamie under her thumb
we'll have to wait and see it's unclear
what the central storyline of season 5
will be during a hall wines happy hour
interview Cole Hauser hinted The Way
season 4 ends the audience will be
happily surprised with a lot of things
who presents the bride me I'm well I'm
the father between the marriage of rip
and bath Casey's Revelation and the
understanding between Beth and Jamie the
next season of Yellowstone promises to
cover new territory the biggest question
heading into season 5 concerns the race
for governor which as John and Jaime
pitted against each other John now owns
Jamie and is threatening his job
prospects leaving plenty of fans to feel
sorry for the way Jaime has been treated
perhaps Jon will reassess their
relationship after notifying the
sheriff's daughter that her father is
dead and recognizing that Beth could
have easily killed his adopted son did I
lose a son today
he was never your son Dad hopefully John
and Jamie will reconcile Casey's Ark
will also be a crucial part of season
five his decision to undergo the warrior
initiation right is sure to earn the
respect of Monica's family it will
undoubtedly affect his view of the world
there's been speculation that Casey may
cross over to the side of the broken
rock Indian Reservation that would
destroy his father
so far every season of Yellowstone
excluding the First with its 90-minute
season premiere has featured 10 one-hour
episodes next season however will be
split into two halves with seven
episodes each the longer 14 episode 5th
season is good news for patient fans you
want me to drive
my drive the fifth season is expected to
help launch several new shows for
Paramount's in-house streamer Paramount
plus Beyond Taylor Sheridan's two
sophomore series 1883 and mayor of
Kingstown among these are the
prohibition era 1923 and the Sylvester
Stallone LED Tulsa King whether these
shows will connect to the greater
Yellowstone story has yet to be revealed
with an extended fifth season and a 10.4
million viewership average on the
Paramount Network Yellowstone shows no
signs of slowing down by far the most
profitable and Below show on the network
Yellowstone and its prequels and
spin-offs are high priorities for the
network meaning we'll likely see more in
the future in May 2022 Paramount
announced that production on season 5 of
Yellowstone had begun in Montana though
the series is largely set in Paradise
Valley in Bozeman it hasn't always
filmed there when Yellowstone premiered
the series was primarily filmed in Park
City Utah southeast of Salt Lake City
the series traveled all across the
beehive state to capture the picturesque
Western landscape however since day one
the Chief Joseph Ranch in Darby Montana
has served as the infamous Yellowstone
Dutton Ranch and most likely will until
the series comes to a close a
family-owned Ranch that Chief Joseph was
well known throughout Montana long
before TV Came Calling after the third
season Yellowstone moved production from
Utah to the film-friendly state of
Montana hoping to honestly brand the
show as a made in Montana production
season 5 continued the tradition filming
in and around the Missoula area and the
western part of the state the story
takes place primarily in Gallatin and
park counties but Yellowstone rarely
films there opting instead to keep
production to the Western end of the
state
while there is no official trailer for
season 5 of Yellowstone just yet there
is a new 15 second teaser that claims
that
[Music]
all will be revealed tell us more what
needs revealing the election results
John or Jamie Casey's New Vision Quest
enhanced world view
what do you see
yes or is it something else entirely
from what we can see in the teaser which
isn't much Casey seems distraught he
puts his head in his hands as he sinks
onto his front porch could this be the
start of conflict between Casey and
Monica or more likely between his family
and the rest of the duttons next we see
rip saddled up with a scoped rifle
There's real trouble Brewing whether
it's human or animal related is up for
debates but one thing is clear rip aims
to teach someone a lesson if you need
something taken care of you tell me
enough take care of it the final teased
moment shows John Dutton walking down a
hallway looking all respectable no doubt
this involves his gubernatorial campaign
he's most likely on his way to give a
speech but what kind Victory or
concession all will be revealed if
you've never watched the single episode
but want to catch up or you want to
revisit the series's best moments before
the season premiere Yellowstone is
available to stream currently all four
seasons can be found on peacock with a
premium option if season 4 taught us
anything it's a paying attention to
small details and earlier seasons will
be rewarded Casey's vision of his dead
brother Lee came as a surprise at the
end of the last season attentive fans
remember that the eldest dutton's son
was killed in battle in the series
opening episode Sheridan's playing the
storytelling long game of course those
who have no interest in binging the
first four seasons can find Recaps on
the Yellowstone YouTube page all in
under 20 minutes if you're curious about
some of the characters from season 4
flashbacks or if you're interested in
the Yellowstone universe beyond the
flagship show the prequel series 1883
can be streamed in its entirety on
Paramount plus the Yellowstone origin
story follows the Dutton family from
Fort Worth Texas across the Great Plains
as they journey to what would eventually
be known as Paradise Valley Montana if
you love classic westerns and this one's
for you
since its Premiere in 2018 Yellowstone
has taken the country and especially the
Paramount Network by storm
I feel different here
skin Tinkles
felt like this before because of its
high production value Stellar cast and
raging popularity the Paramount network
runs frequent Yellowstone marathons no
doubt there run another ahead of the
season 5 premiere marathons increase
interest and excitement leading up to
the return of a popular program and some
of the greatest TV shows in history have
done the same in preparation for a new
season especially if it can secure more
consistent viewership for their networks
going forward for those interested in
binging all of Yellowstone with
commercials simply search online for
information about the next big scheduled
Marathon like the one the network ran
over Labor Day weekend of course you
could easily binge the past four seasons
on peacock but where's the challenge in
that
it's entirely possible that Taylor
Sheridan could end the Yellowstone Saga
with the fifth season especially since
he has a half dozen other Paramount
projects in the making it seems unlikely
though that the network would want to
fold on this modern Western just yet
many episodes throughout season 4 felt
like backdoor Pilots for other series
which generated huge criticism even from
long time fans of the show Jimmy's time
down at the poor sixes Ranch in Texas
was no doubt a way to explore the world
of 666 long before the show's Premiere
and the flashbacks to the late 1800s
Stutton family led by Tim McGraw and
Faith Hill where an obvious precursor to
1883. it seems that Sheridan is doing
everything he can to expand his
Yellowstone Empire before it loses steam
you are the trailer park
I am the tornado it's unclear where the
story of the Dutton family can still go
if they aren't going to give up their
land to developers natives of the
government then who else is there left
to fight and if Casey and his family
really are done with the Yellowstone for
good then who is John Dutton actually
fighting for if Yellowstone has taught
us anything it's that one day it will
all be gone the duttons their legacy and
possibly their open land though we hope
Yellowstone sticks around a while longer
everything eventually comes to an end
oh